en un acto estrictamente cerrado y ante
pocos invitados el presidente manuel
merino juramento ántero flores-aráoz
como primer ministro de este gobierno de
transición ante los flores es un
destacado político y abogado fue elegido
por merino para brindarle credibilidad y
prestigio a su gestión en momentos en
que los ciudadanos rechazan a su
gobierno con protestas en las calles en
diferentes regiones del perú a esta hora
antero florez trabaja con el presidente
manuel merino en la nómina de ministros
que integrarán este nuevo gobierno
flórez ha dicho que el perú vive una
crisis económica muy fuerte con
desempleo galopante además de la crisis
sanitaria y no es el mejor momento para
hacer experimentos por eso los
principales desafíos que tendrán que
afrontar son mejorar la atención a la
pandemia el kobe 19 impulsar la
recuperación económica
alentar el empleo porque más de 6
millones de peruanos perdieron su
puestos de trabajo por la pandemia pero
el reto mayor va a ser conquistar el
apoyo de la población que no acepta la
destitución de martín vizcarra